the Joe Rogan experience Tony Ferguson
Tony Perkins is a nano an animal like
that he's a scary sky 1:55 Martin my
word I agree
in my world because you don't get tired
it that cowboy fight freak me out
he what cowboy looked like Tony had
bricks in his gloves yeah
his face was all busted up Tony didn't
look like you had a scratch on him and
Tony wasn't even tired
Tony posted a meme I feel like a couple
days ago he showed like his last seven
yes they're all [ __ ] up like they
they're all fell off a train yeah yeah
it's crazy man he has insane power man
he it's like it's a weird thing cuz Tony
does stuff to people and doesn't he
doesn't get tired he doesn't get to eat
like he's legit crazy yes like he does
it like I don't know if he feels pain
that kind of crazy you know I mean like
he will do things in there that I
remember when we fought I'm southpaw
he's Orthodox right he throws that
inside kick and I'm turning my leg over
to check it and like it was never at my
knee he was throwing that at my shin
like if you're throwing that calf kick
Oh with that open stance you're throwing
it out the Shannon right you know I mean
so like I checked it and um I was like I
was about to check and then we Bank shin
to shin like the middle of the shin to
the middle of his shin mm-hmm and I
remember thinking myself why the [ __ ]
would you do that now I both heard like
I seriously hated that feeling but he
did like there was no reaction on his
face there was nothing he was just like
still on just on to the next thing and I
feel like I'm glad I fought it men cuz
like look at him now he's psychotic you
know 20 versus last seven opponents
Jesus Christ get all bloody
masses even like his to what the things
he posts like he get an insight to how
crazy his mind is did you see his post
his press conference after um after um
Sergio after Anthony Pettis no yeah he
was taught he's talking about he was
gonna be a doctor
he said we I think he said something
like he said what did he say he said um
he said oh you say you know what they
call me cuz he's like yeah he's GQ guy
he's talking about Anthony he's a GQ guy
but you know what they call me
they call me the GQ Killa you know what
that is it's an awesome nickname I would
like to see what his conditioning
workout is cuz Eddie goes with him up to
Big Bear you know and he trains them and
he says you never seen anything like it
he said everybody else in camp can't
keep up with them who works out he goes
I've never seen anybody have this kind
of dedication in gas-tank city works out
a legitimate six hours a day
he says he's running hills they do these
hill sprints and he said he laps
everybody he goes all the way to the top
before they do goes down and then beats
them on the way up I said it just
doesn't get tired yeah I don't noticed
it what does someone doing when they're
there cardio is so much better than
everybody else's because the cowboy
fight I'm telling you man I watched him
from the moment they stopped the fight
after the second round I'm watching him
and he goes back to his corner Cowboys
face is a mess he's just beating the
[ __ ] out of cowboy he goes back to his
corner his stomach isn't even heaving
yeah he's not breathing heavy I'm not
gonna lie to you
I don't want to see this fight because I
like both those guys but as a fight fan
I want to see this fight and that's him
and Dustin Oh him and don't be insane
cuz like that those are two guys who
don't know how to quit well if Dustin
beats could be that's the fight yeah and
if Dustin doesn't beat could be Tony and
khabib the fight yeah they'll fight
eventually I'm sure yeah I mean that is
a crazy-ass fight but the thing is like
Tony's pace is so disturbing
it's so disturbing because I watched him
fight guys and I'm like how do you keep
up with that nobody keeps up with it but
you got to crack him
you got a catch like Anthony caught him
but he broke his hand but Pettis had him
hurt and he and Lando had him hurt Lando
venado cracked I've never heard yeah
yeah yeah but like knows how to survive
though yeah exactly and also it's weird
because he doesn't survive like most
people do he doesn't tie you up and try
to get it try to recollect itself like
he's just
fights yeah and he like he and stay like
scramble you heard him he puts it on you
he's like okay I need a break meaning
I'm coming after you now hey you're
gonna have to stop me from killing you
so that I take a break yeah I've just
I'm always stunned at his pace in his
cardio it's it's me I really like I just
want to know is this scientifically
planned like are they monitoring his
heart rate or is this just psychotic
I guess it's scientific or is a
psychotic I think it's the latter I
think it might be I think I'd like Tony
first if if there's a scary movie Tony
Ferguson would be that guy he's out
Cucuy
yeah he's the boogeyman they need they
need to make a movie out like somebody
needs to do some kind of like I don't
know mashup of his fight huh that make
him seem like like the Jason the guy
that just never goes away and as soon as
you turn around he's ready to kill you
well you just think about Luke Thomas
posted some tweet where the last time
Tony's first in one like who was
champion and what was going on the
world's like 2013 is the last time he
lost and he lost to Michael Johnson yeah
also be Dustin yeah yeah those Dustin's
last loss as well
[Applause]